so i wasn't quite expecting the
emotional ride
that this movie provided for me there's
so much depth to the characters and the
story was this something that you loved
about the movie
oh yeah that was definitely something
that attracted me to the movie
uh it's the the depth the character
the the different characters the love
the community
and uh the life that was in the script
i loved it too uh it reminded me
especially when i saw it of the i don't
know if you're old enough for this
but the abc after school specials i used
to run home to see
yeah um after school
all the time that um emotional like
uplifting
true storytelling it was
so authentic and so genuinely told
and so kind of like multi-dimensional
from every aspect of every character so
i was
i loved that about it you both have a
really
emotional scene with aoli who's just
such an amazing actress and singer what
was it like working with her
fantastic she's just so she's so present
i mean that really is the word for her
and
and my experience with her she's so
present it's a back and forth
she's a great acting partner she's so
young and already
so uh solid you know she's solid with
everything
solid with her work ethic and solid with
her acting and
solid as a human being so it was
fantastic yeah she's really there for
the whole thing
really excited um and just knows
everybody
and and she's down for anything that you
have to offer
so it's really fun to see and really
reminiscent of when i first started
acting really a lot of fun to be around
yeah wow well and true you know like
when a movie is kind of resting on your
shoulders as well you know there's that
pressure there but it sounds like she
was always kind of
positive on set he was he really was it
was a great team though that did
you know brett was great uh you everyone
was very supportive
and uh and and respectful of each other
and everything was done with a lot of
love actually yeah
it was great the portland the crew
everyone it was just fantastic yeah and
i feel like
you can feel that in the movie yeah you
can feel it in the movie
yeah i feel like that that everyone was
excited to be there and everybody was
happy and the people behind the camera
the people in front of the camera you
felt it
well we have to talk about carol burnett
i mean what's it like to have
a comedy genius like her a part of this
film
we don't know we didn't meet her i know
i was going to say did you meet her on
set at all at any point walked by her
trailer
no i have that and justina knows i'm a
little bitter about this
well what did you think of her
performance in the film she was
wonderful
come on she's careless
and how excited they are with each other
and each other's company you know and
now she kind of like uh
kind of like works counter to like that
reputation that she has as this comedic
genius and you know
she just has a lot of fun with playing
that character
but um you know i'm just like i didn't
get to meet her
no it's terrific it's just terrific and
i'm very proud to be part of
you know this film with her in it no i
love it i love everything about it
well a big you know story line with this
film is amber has
difficulty accepting help from others so
have either of you had moments in your
life where you struggled accepting help
from others when you
you you needed it oh yeah yeah because
you know especially growing up latina
you know it's like you're
you're not supposed to it's all supposed
to stay in the family
you know you're not supposed to the
neighbors or this or it and
it's it's not something that i was
taught you know but so it was very
difficult it was very easy for me
to give always it was difficult for me
to receive which is what amber's story
is too it's difficult
it's great for her to give but it's
difficult for her to receive
and it took many many many years for me
to be okay with it and to ask for it and
i do
i ask for help every time i need help
and i reach for my community every time
i need them
but it took me a while i i have to agree
i think i grew up the same way you know
i think as like first generation
immigrants
and things like that there was some kind
of uh stigma
attached to and i still i get emotional
even talking about it now and watching
it
um about uh that stigma that was
attached to asking for it
it's almost like you would get in
trouble you know um
as someone who is not american back in
the day of asking i said no no
no no no no but you always offer help as
a christian you offer
but as an immigrant you don't ask oh wow
it's a very very painful thing to
witness because um
everyone was so willing it was like
almost that you would get in trouble or
she would get caught
for being a person without a home you
know
and and so she would always kind of like
you could see
her character lee doing a wonderful job
showing you
that math that she was doing in her head
you know if she would actually just um
accept any kind of help
like you know the trail would go back to
being found out that she
had no home or that you know she was in
trouble or something was going on with
her mom
or anything like that you know and and
and
she was elevated to a place where
everyone eventually just showed her
no we're gonna we have your back yeah
well this film was so beautiful i
enjoyed it so much and it was such a
pleasure to talk to both of you thanks
so much guys
thank you
you